Oh Rhys and the cast of a wrinkle in
time taken us exclusively behind the
scenes of their new fantasy adventure
accent I read the book when I was
probably 12 and I just loved it and I
have read every book in this series this
young girl on the journey to find her
father and herself what a story you're
going to be tested every step of the way
Oprah Reese and Mindy Kaling are three
celestial guides leading a young girl on
her journey through time and space
hi I'm mrs. Weston mrs. sweet this is
you this is my favorite planet the
entire galaxy for two weeks the cast and
crew shot in the same New Zealand
location as Lord of the Rings to capture
stunning scenes like this it was amazing
to watch this harmony of hundreds of
people coming to make this film the film
marks a historic milestone for director
Ava Duvernay she's the first woman of
color to direct a feature with a
production budget of over 100 million
dollars we're really trying to create a
film that has that timeless quality on
location it was all about the girl power
this great adventure of a film has been
one of the great adventures of my own
life get better for me
whoo you can't do better than that cast
amazing in Ava yeah all right well
Disney to wrinkle in time opens marks
the night
[Music]